- (people chanting) Rah!
Rah!
Rah! Rah!
- To the wall.
- Often, the hardest thing
in science fiction
is coming up
with a point of view
for the world
that you're creating.
- We spend most of our time with
our hero tribe, which is the Alkenny.
- Baba Voss is
the leader of the tribe.
- (people chanting) See!
- He's got a responsibility
to protect their village
and his family.
The tribe is a mountain tribe,
maybe 65, 75 people,
somewhat isolated
from the other tribes.
- Uh, as the show goes on,
we get to open up the world
and see a lot of
different tribes.
We have a plastic tribe,
we have a metal tribe,
we have the rope tribe,
which is our Alkenny.
The world isn't just
our small, little universe.
We are creating an entire world.
(thunder crashes)
- Something's different.
These children, they have
the ability to see.
Now they will come for us.
- If vision disappeared for 600 years,
even the concept of it would be gone.
There would be
no way of describing what it is,
and so,
for the people who don't have it,
when it returns,
it's witchcraft and it's evil.
- Baba Voss' tribe exists
within a larger nation
called the Payan Nation
that is governed by a queen.
Queen Kane's afraid
that people with vision
might have a power over her,
and so she sends the witchfinder
out to look for the children.
- For centuries we feared
this day would come.
The evil of the light once
almost destroyed the world.
And now, it has returned.
Find the children who can see,
and bring them to me.
- These two children,
their true father
is kind of a mythical figure
named Jerlamarel.
- These children are a gift.
They will bring knowledge.
They will begin a new world.
- They're the first humans
that have been able to see
in hundreds and hundreds of years.
So, together,
they have to protect the children.
- I have to keep you safe.
- I have been looking for you...
...for a lifetime.
(shouting)
(shouts)